oye viene a jugar por la fama todos
saben quién soy siempre adelante nunca
veo atrás yo soy el mejor entérate
[Aplausos]
algunas aplicaciones de citas
e
cómo describiría su vida amorosa en una
palabra modesta ver qué sucede no es
importante diría seca soltero está
solitaria que entra en las chicas
[Música]
soy cristian estudio en la acb en
riverside mi nombre es marcus medio
tiempo estudio y el otro trabajo soy
queilén trabajo medio tiempo y tengo 18
años soy quien uno de queens nueva york
y soy productor y modelo soy wesley
acabo de graduarme de la universidad soy
jailin soy productor de música y rapero
5 4 3 2
ahora
estoy lista
[Música]
soy rebeca rebeca justo en conocer west
en conocerte qué tal chicos
hoy le gusta su estilo
soy de nueva york con su la pasó bien en
brooklyn apenas escuchó el acento digo
quiero conocer a esa persona llegamos
aquí debemos permanecer juntos debemos
seguir juntos que sientes al tener una
línea larga de chica nerviosa porque
crees que el resultado fue así crees que
haya sido algo que dijiste así que
dijiste que tengo 18 crees que fue por
eso sí puedes lamer tu codo podría
salvarse en la eliminación por ejemplo
sólo practicó solo
está bien es imposible hacer lo
imposible crecí jugando lacrosse si
juego la cruz también o genial si bien
aún juegas jugué en la universidad o tal
vez nunca deberíamos jugar lacrosse
juntos porque no creo que eso sería muy
divertido la primera eliminación es en
un minuto
cuáles son sus secretos más oscuros qué
profundo las
relaciones públicas en televisión
rodeada de creatividad mental bueno sí
sí me encanta ser creativo saber
supuesto tal vez porque somos de nueva
york dime tres palabras que describan
diría tímido e introvertido
y si hago el beat puedes hacer estilo
libre está bien lo haré aquí mismo se
está
oye viene a jugar por la fama todos
saben quién soy siempre adelante nunca
pero atrás yo soy el mejor entérate
es difícil decir
bueno elimina a alguien
bien
cielos lo siento
a
bueno a ti esta bici
sí
debemos hacer esto ahora cinco segundos
dos valles
4 3 2 1 lo siento
no hay problema debes eliminar a otra
persona en un minuto mi cumpleaños se
acerca tienes
aún nada podemos planificar algo
podemos hacer una fiesta un baile
favorito mi movimiento favorito es el
dépor
quien te inspiró para ser rapero fue
linkin park chester sí que era muy fan
de linkin park y lo intenté tanto y
llegue lejos eso lo realizaron también
final
parece un buen trabajo sí bueno es la
carrera que vas a es como pre medicina
es eso elimina a alguien
es la parte más difícil
los cielos
está bien sí
lo siento lo siento puedes decirme sobre
qué es el tatuaje antes de irte después
bien lo siento como te defines a ti
mismo como artísticamente como músico si
me gusta hacer diferentes cosas venía
cuántico con eso como cual es un buen
que género de la arte te identificas
diría que en música o genia chicas deben
pelear a muerte ahora bien no consolidar
el amor no que así me gusta en un clan
no traicionamos a las personas ustedes
saben eso si me gusta mucho drake
el baby elimina a alguien o rayos
i
cuál es el objetivo del claro
de la crisis climática
cuáles son tus metros esté estudiando
para el examen de derecha que hay de ti
estudió psicología acabo de graduarme de
la escuela preparatoria que les gustó
sobre ustedes tiene un alma bondadosa y
tiene buena energía es amistosa
enseguida estábamos hablando de tus
diferentes amigos nos llevamos bien
tienes un buen plan aquí en los ángeles
a veces es un poco difícil pero quiero
seguir adelante porque él y nomura
versión
que o rayos
sí sí
voy
lo siento
sólo porque eres más alta que yo está
bien te entiendo los seis en tacones
beniel de rifle no sé también me quedaré
en el clan puedes comer sushi todo el
tiempo y puedo sido sus y todos los días
también comiste con sus ideas maravillas
eliminó a alguien
[Risas]
fue un placer igualmente seguimos
hablando o seguimos hablando
[Música]
qué opinan de la experiencia en general
fue una conversación muy natural y
tenemos mucho en común fue divertido si
es raro pero a la vez divertido la pasé
bien
un poco de miedo hacer como si nada
excepto que hay 30 personas viendo
hablar
creen que tal vez se vuelvan a reunir
fuera de aquí a mí me gustaría sí creo
que sí seguro creo que ya sí yo me anoto
segunda
minutos me anotó también si parece
inteligente podría de aprender mucho de
ella gracias
jubilee vive intensamente